foreign
so this woman recently gives birth
and her husband demands that she pay the
entire hospital bill herself
now there's more to the story they've
been married seven years she just had
her their first baby three months ago
they split everything in their marriage
50 50 when it comes to finances and
generally keep their money separate
and everything seemed to be going pretty
well until they received a hospital bill
for this birth so here's the deal she
planned to give birth to any medication
but after 24 hours of Labor decided to
do the epidural and when the bill came
her husband expected her to pay the
entire eight grand Bill herself and when
she asked why he said you're the one who
couldn't hold out for a few more hours
and you jacked up the bill and I
shouldn't have to pay for all these
extra requests and then finally if she
wanted luxury she should expect to pay
for it oh my God if you tried that on
Sheila what would happen what hell would
break loose here's the thing I wouldn't
even be I wouldn't know you wouldn't get
the sentence Because by the time those
words left my mouth I would already be
at the gates
and I don't know which set of gates I
would be at if I said something like
this now if you're wondering all the
extra you know what jacked up this bill
well of course the epidural very
expensive uh lactation consultant
Nursery fee extra night stay postpartum
supplies any food she ate so all of that
made the bill go up and so he goes well
that was your decision so you should pay
for that that's not coming out of my
pile of the pot so she ended up paying
the entire bill on her own and she's now
wondering and questioning are her
feelings valid John okay so I had
somebody call my show a few years ago
and here's the question
um it she had a two-year-old and a seven
month old and she was with her boyfriend
and he let her know
um I want to let you know that I'm not
considering you
for the role of my wife but two things
you're gonna have to a get my house back
in order because this place is a wreck
like you're just not taking care of the
house and B you're gonna have to get
your body back because let's be honest
you let that sucker go and when you get
that back and she and here's the deal
she was calling me to ask
how she could be more disciplined and I
was like oh honey like oh man I've got a
few friends that would not mind going
back to jail what's his address or right
so it's a it's a it's easy when you're
when somebody is is so is gaslighting
you so bad is is so out to lunch you
think you're the start to look in the
mirror and be like oh it must clearly
it's me I'm the problem it's not them
yes they've been very clear that it's
it's not it's not them it's me I'm the
problem yes I
wow wow so this is an abusive
relationship very clearly but it's an
insane relationship and but here's the
thing I do want to call out to there's
uh I don't have 10 million people
listening right now half of you and I
know it's half of you because that's how
much negative negative press we get
I'm never gonna I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna share a checking account I'm not
gonna share bills we split this thing 50
50. this is the end result of that and
if it's not if you're like no no I mean
I would help with the with the baby
where's your line dude when you set up a
my life in your life and we're married
into the same roof this is the root of
that crap that happens right this is
this is the end result down the road of
people who don't say hey we're married
we're in come hell or high water we're
both in on this deal this is that bull
crap button oh sorry bro you should just
held out bro
so he's driving a truck through you he's
like well man you should just should
have just hung out man I don't know how
this man is still alive truthfully what
an idiot so I don't know I mean
truthfully I don't know if the marriage
is going to survive no if this is how it
continues if this is the attitude
towards it and we know that divorce and
money fights are one of the leading
causes uh money problems and money
fights leading cause of divorce another
leading cause of divorce made sense when
you look at being married to an idiot
that's another one or absolutely more a
poor choice was made at some point
but we teach people that you should
combine finances 100 when you get
married
no earlier but as soon as you're married
combined finances your team it's we it's
not well that's your bill so well I'll
cover electricity you cover the wad I I
got the food last month when we ate out
that's an insane way to live if you
wanted a roommate don't get married is
that simple yes
if you want to go back to being
roommates you can do that and by the way
for the first time in uh Ramsay show
history we're gonna add a few other
recommendations husbands don't look at
your wife and say an epidural is a
luxury you could have waited a few more
hours don't ever say that ever never say
that
um lactation consultant not a luxury not
a luxury here's a here's the thing
gentlemen in case you don't know this
babies
and uh have to eat they have to eat
um here's another one Nursery fee so
babies can stay in the room with you is
it insane that hospitals charge that yes
it is but
um I don't know throughout all of human
history until about 60 years ago babies
always slept in the same room with their
new parent like dude don't be insane
don't be Georgia man I told you it was
gonna grind your gears this is the
opposite of hemorrhoids this has got me
so puckered up I want to know this guy I
want to find this guy wow we went from
visual to visceral thank you John I I
can't I'm I'm just trying to imagine how
this would go in my house and I just
wouldn't here's what would happen you
and and probably Dave and maybe Rachel
there'd be a couple of y'all at this
desk and there'd be a box of tissues and
you'd just be saying like John's dead
John's dead and uh he won't be doing the
show he had a good life he had a good
life but man he sure was stupid when it
came to one of his children being born
wow